muddy water and debris blanketing much
of the State of California
one area getting half the precipitation
it usually gets in a year
in just 16 days the reason eight
so-called atmospheric rivers in a row
since late December and here we are by
some estimates 22 to 25 trillion gallons
of water have fallen over the course
last 16-17 days a stacking of these
atmospheric Rivers the likes of which
we've not experienced in our lifetimes
atmospheric rivers are long streams of
moisture from the tropics they get
caught in the jet stream and carry
tremendous amounts of water
this is just the latest one flooding
Caitlin Clancy's home three times since
the beginning of the month and the
cleanup was awful but you know we
cleaned it up and then next thing you
know
fast forward like what six days was it I
don't know uh we're flooding again so we
were in shock because even though we
prepped for it we didn't prep for it to
get as high as it had and so that was
even more mess and more destruction
it's impacting much of the state in the
mountains dumping 54 centimeters of snow
in just 24 hours
in the Hills charred by wildfires the
soil is unable to retain much moisture
in the long term that means all of this
rain will do little to ease California's
drought right now it's causing major
mudslides and sending massive Boulders
into valleys
roads are being washed away sinkholes
making travel impossible and in drought
stricken California thousands of Trees
weakened by the floods are now being
knocked down by wind gusts of up to 96
kilometers an hour
people have been killed and power
knocked out for tens of thousands this
major emergency declaration will allow
cities and states to use some federal
money to help cover the costs of the
rescues in the recovery it will provide
grants to people who need to find
temporary shelters or make minor repairs
for those who don't have insurance they
can get low interest loans from the
government to help them rebuild
more people will need that help the next
atmospheric river is expected to hit
Sunday evening and last through Monday
Patty culhane Al Jazeera Washington